My husband really wanted a Fanta with his meal today,
and since we didn't have any,
I decided to make him some.
Fanta always reminds me of summer spent at the beach,
so I ended up craving it as well.
I started by steeping some gentian tea.
After about five minutes, I popped that in the fridge so it could cool.
In the meantime,
I zested about four oranges and made sure to get all the skin off
before combining that with some sugar and really working it in.
After it was all combined,
I put it away in an airtight container
so that the sugar could pull out the oils
for about four hours, and after that,
I started combining all of my ingredients.
Poured my tea, some water,
the sugar mixture, some ascorbic acid,
malic acid, and citric acid into my blender,
started blending that until everything was combined,
and then passed it through a fine mesh strainer,
poured some of the Fanta syrup into a glass,
top that with cold sparkling water,
and our Fanta was done.
This tasted so divine that lucky ended up chugging it.
It was exactly what I was craving as well.